okay please there's so much news to get
to
please I I love your love but there is
so much news but I tell you between
March Madness bracket and Stormy Daniels
what a week for big busts huh
yes all week everybody's been on pins
and needles because we thought the word
was going to come down that Trump was
going to be indicted and arrested and
it's true Trump may be indicted in a
criminal investigation and everybody in
this country said the same thing which
one
it's the one with Stormy Daniels
Trump the first guy ever to pay a porn
star to shut her mouth
and okay so now because this is all
anybody's thinking about a lot of these
deep fakes you know these deep fakes
they can make anything look like
anything have been going viral look at
this one this is uh yeah this people are
looking at this you could tell
you can tell this is fake because Trump
is running
um
I missed one night I saw one of uh
Melania oh you can tell
because she's upset uh but
but you know it could get
I know what he thinks you know his crowd
is roused up about this could get
violent so he today called for calm I'm
kidding of course
[Applause]
he made it worse he posted that if he
gets arrested or charged
he warned a potential death and
destruction
that would be catastrophic catastrophic
for our country what is known as an
unveiled threat
makes you missed those innocent days
when he just undermined faith in our
elections you know
but stormy now poor stormy she's caught
in the middle in the middle of this and
now she's getting threats from Trump's
crazy people and boy if they're mad at
stormy about this what did they find out
what Debbie did to Dallas
of course I think the person was really
laughing about all this is Hillary
she's she's home going who's getting
locked up now
[Applause]